it's unspeakable to you why I fathered
it's your family that was unspeakable
what Rhaegar Targaryen did to your
sister the woman I loved
I'll kill every Targaryen I get my hands
on you can't get your hands on this one
Kenya what's up ladies and gentlemen
welcome back for another game of Thor
and slash a Song of Ice and Fire video
thanks to Game of Thrones one of the
biggest theories was confirmed at last
season we found out that Rhaegar and
Lyanna were actually married which makes
Jon Snow the true heir to the Seven
Kingdoms this is something most of us
fans already saw coming because this has
been a very popular theory for a very
long time the clues were hidden very
well but once you pick up on the scent
the clues become a lot easier to see so
today I want to show you some of the
clues from the books and I'm pretty sure
all of the ones you will see today we're
not provided in the show a won't bother
talking about the Tornillo of Harrenhal
or the Tower of joy because everyone
should have heard enough about that in
the television show by now I will admit
that most of these clues or hints are
very subjective some of you may see
these as reaching while others may not
but I wanted to mainly make this video
for people that have not read the books
because you may not realize that george
RR martin was hinting at Jon Snow being
a king for a very long time I know some
people still believe Jon Snow is a
bastard or he is not the son of Rhaegar
and Lyanna but I really don't want to
get into that today I just want to show
you the things that I think point to Jon
being the legitimate son of Rhaegar
Targaryen making him the king of
Westeros the first thing I want to show
you is on the very first page of John's
very first chapter in a game of Thrones
the reason why I want to show you this
one first is because this one is the
easiest to disregard it's just one word
that doesn't really prove anything but I
thought it was a very interesting word
to use in Jon's very first page now that
i know george RR martin is a master at
leaving breadcrumbs i wouldn't put it
past him to leave hints at the very
beginning of the story this is what
Jon's very first chapter says a singer
was playing the high harp and reciting a
ballad
but down at this end of the hall his
voice could scarcely be heard above the
roar of the fire the clangor of the
pewter plates and cups in the low mutter
of a hundred drunken conversations the
reason why they stuck out to me was
because it immediately reminded me of
rhaegar targaryen we don't know much
about this man but we do know that he
loves to sing and play his harp his
singing was so beautiful it actually
made Liana cry so as I was reading the
books again this really stuck out to me
because I thought it was interesting
that George decided to talk about
someone singing and playing the harp on
John's first page now this might not be
anything at all but I couldn't ignore it
this next one is from Eddard Starks very
first chapter of the first book this is
when he's talking to Robert Baratheon as
they are heading to lay on a statue Ned
Stark says Kings are a rare sight in the
north
Robert snorts and says more likely they
were hiding under the snow snow Ned now
if you believe the theory that John is
the legitimate son of Rhaegar Targaryen
then you could say John is a king and
hiding under the bastard named snow the
true king was hiding in Winterfell all
along by Ned Stark and he kept in hidden
by giving him the name snow in saying he
was his bastard son there is something
else I want to point out in John's first
chapter as John was talking to his uncle
Benjen about joining the Nights Watch
benjin was trying to tell John that he
was still too young to join he really
didn't want John to throw away other
opportunities he may have in his life
but John was very adamant about leaving
Winterfell and taking the black so John
tells benjin this Darrin Targaryen was
only 14 when he conquered Dorne the
young dragon was one of his heroes this
doesn't really prove much either but I
thought it was interesting that George
was planning the seeds of a Targaryen
connection very early in John's chapters
the young dragon was one of John's
heroes and John may be a young dragon
himself benjin also tells John that the
young dragon died by the age of 18 which
is very close to the same age that John
died now let's move on at Ariens second
chapter in a game of Thrones this quote
is said while Jon and Tyrion are
traveling to the wall together they set
up camp for the
night and John notices Tyrion is reading
a book and Tyrion tells John that he's
reading a book about dragons
Tyrion says when I was your age I used
to dream of having a dragon of my own
then Tyrion says don't look at me that
way bastard I know your secret you've
dreamt the same kind of dreams we never
hear about Jon having any dreams about
dragons but sometimes I feel like this
is George trying to speak directly to us
in John's fourth chapter he's at the
wall and he's having a conversation was
a mo Tarly this is when Sam tells John
about his father and how he forced him
to join the Nights Watch but in the
books Jon tell Sam about his dream where
he's wandering around the crypts of
Winterfell and this is what he says the
old kings of winter are down there
sitting on their thrones with stone
wolves at their feet and iron swords
across their laps but it's not them I'm
afraid of ice cream that I'm not a stark
that this isn't my place but it's no
good I have to go anyway so I start down
feeling the walls as I descend with no
torch to light the way it gets darker
and darker until I want to scream now
you could say the reason why Jon feels
like he doesn't belong down there is
because he's a bastard and he knows he
will never have a spot of his own down
in the crypts but if you believe in the
theory then you know it's much more than
this John does have stark blood but he
knows he's not a stark and we know he's
a Targaryen that's really why this isn't
his place now this next one has some
really great wordplay in it this is when
Arya is staying at King's Landing and
she's training with Syrio Forel
he has Arya chasing cats all over the
Red Keep and Arya runs into one of the
gold cloaks as she's chasing them one by
one
arya had chased them down and snatched
them up and brought them proudly to
Syrio Forel all of them but this one
this one eared black devil of a tomcat
that's the real king of this castle
right there
one of the gold cloaks had told her
older than sin and twice's mean one time
the king was feasting the Queen's father
and that black bastard hopped up on the
table and snatched a roast quail right
out of Lord Tywin's fingers
there are two key phrases in this quote
the first one is wear the gold cloak
says that's the real king of this castle
right there
then he refers to the cat as a black
bastard
now which character and their story
could be considered a black bastard who
just might be the actual king of the
castle there are at least four different
times in the books that John is called a
black bastard for one he is a bastard
because that's what we're told at first
and John joins the Nights Watch which
means he wears all black John took the
black making him a black bastard he is
the true king of the castle in King's
Landing this was hidden very well but if
you're paying attention to what George
is doing here then he kind of sticks out
during a second or third reading let's
move on to one ahead orgs chapters in
the TV show this is one Littlefinger
takes Ned to see the last person Jon
Arryn spoke with before he died it's the
mother of one of King Robert's bastards
and Ned meets with her in Littlefinger's
brothel
Ned is realizing that all of Robert's
bastards have black hair unlike his kids
with Cersei in the books this happens a
little differently because we get to go
inside Ned Stark's head and hear what
he's thinking when Ned meets what one of
Roberts mistresses she says tell him
that when you see him my lord as it as
it please you tell him how beautiful she
is Ned says I will Ned had promised her
and he thought of the promises he'd made
Leona as she lay dying and the price
that he paid to keep them I will tell
him child and I promise you bara shall
not go one ting she had smiled then a
smile so tremulous and sweet that it cut
the heart right out of him right after
Ned leaves he's riding through the rainy
night and he sees Jon Snow's face right
in front of him now why would Ned be
picturing Jon Snow right after he
started to think about the promise he
made to Leona could it be because Ned
promised to keep Jon safe just like Ned
was trying to do with Robert's bastards
but the next thing that thinks about
makes this even more interesting after
he thinks about Liana's promise and he
sees John's face Ned immediately starts
to remember Rhaegar Targaryen he
wondered if Rhaegar had freaked
brothels but he thought not so as you
can see as soon as Ned starts to think
about Leona he pictures John snows face
then he starts to think about Rhaegar
for the first time in years
it was Liana and John that made Ned
think about Rhaegar for the first time
in years this secret is eating Ned Stark
alive but he knows it was the right
thing to do or else John would be dead
this next one really feels like George
is trying to tell us something and the
second book of Clash of Kings John is
having a conversation with Lord
Commander Mormont and the Lord Commander
is telling John about maester aemon's
life in some of the history of the most
recent Targaryen Kings Mormont tells
John about maester aemon's father his
brothers in the Mad King then he says
Jaime Lannister put an end to the line
of the Dragon Kings when he killed the
Mad King
but then lor Commander Mormont's Ravan
croaked King the bird flapped across the
solar to land on Mormont shoulder King
it said again strutting back and forth
he likes that word John said as he
smiled
Mormont then stroked the raven under the
beak with a finger but all the while the
Ravens eyes never left Jon Snow that's
interesting because as soon as the Lord
Commander Mormont said all the Dragon
Kings are dead the raven looked at john
and said king then the raven said King
again and it never took its eyes off of
John and as we all know Bloodraven is
most likely controlling the Ravens the
writer is discretely telling us that not
all of the Dragon Kings are dead because
Jon Snow is next in line in another one
of John's chapters a very interesting
story is told to him by Ygritte after
Jon captures g-great she overhears that
John is the bastard of Winterfell and
this reminds her of an old song but John
isn't too familiar with it
so yeegar precedes to tell John the
story in my opinion this has a pretty
clear connection to Rhaegar and Lyanna
story but you be the judge this is what
she tells John Bale the bard made it
said Ygritte he was king-beyond-the-wall
a long time back all the free folk know
his songs but might be you don't sing
them in the south the stark in
Winterfell wanted bales head but never
could take him and the taste of failure
one day in his bitterness he called
Balak Raven who prayed only on the week
when Warda vet got back bail vowed to
teach the Lord a lesson so he scaled the
wall he skipped down the Kings Road and
walked in to Winterfell one winter's
night with harp and hand naming himself
seeger ik of sky goes sea Greek means
deceiver in the old tongue that the
first men spoke and the Giants still
speak north or south singers always find
already welcome so Bale ate at Lord
Starks own table and played for the Lord
in his high seat until half the night
was gone he played and sang so well that
when he was done the Lord offered to let
him name his own reward all I ask is a
flower Bailey answered the fairest
flower that blooms in the gardens of
Winterfell so the Starks sent to his
glass gardens and commanded that the
most beautiful winter roses be plucked
for the singers payment and so it was
done but when morning come the singer
had vanished and so had Lord Brandon's
maiden daughter her bed they found empty
but for the pale blue rose that bale had
left on the pillow where her head had
lain John had never heard this tale
before Lord Brandon had no other
children for most to hear they searched
for any sign a bail or this made till
the Lord lost heart and took to his bed
and it seemed as though the line of
Starks was at its end but one night as
he lay waiting to die Lord Brandon heard
a child's cry he followed the sound and
found his daughter back in her
bedchamber asleep with a babe at her
breast they had been in Winterfell all
the time hiding with the dead beneath
the castle the maid loved veil so dearly
she bore him a son the song says now
let's look at the connections here first
we have a blue winter rose just like the
blue went to Rose Rhaegar gave Liana
then we have the young stark daughter
who goes missing
just like Liana went missing with
Rhaegar then the young stark daughter
has a child because she had fell in love
with him and she bore him a son just
like Leone a dip with Rhaegar now let me
ask all of you this why do you think the
first time
this story is introduced in the books it
is being told to Jon Snow I think you
know the answer to that what is very
interesting is what Jon starts to do
shortly after he has told this story
Jon begins to question who he really is
this story must have triggered something
in Jon he then tells Ygritte I never
meant to steal you I never knew you were
a girl until my knife was at your throat
if you kill a man and never meant he's
just as dead he Girt said stubbornly Jon
had never met anyone so stubborn except
maybe for his little sister Arya then
Jon thinks to himself if she stole my
sister
he wondered was she ever my sister the
answer is no Jon Arya is not your sister
Jon's identity crisis is really starting
to intensify but like I said at the
beginning of the video all of this stuff
is subjective I'm sure some people
aren't going to look at this the same
way I do which is fine
I believe this next one is foreshadowing
two different things next we go to the
last book A Dance with Dragons and this
one's in the prologue this involved a
character known as Vera mere six skins
for those of you who don't know who he
is he is one of the wildlings from
manses party he is well known for being
able to skin change six different
animals he had wolves shadow cats
and even a bear he's basically the
zookeeper beyond the wall anyways he
ends up getting stabbed and he's dying
so he knows he needs to warg into
something quick so he can continue to
live through his conscious as he's
thinking about what to do he starts to
think about John and his direwolf ghost
this is what he thinks he had known what
Snow was the moment he saw that great
white dire wolf stalking silent at his
side one skin-changer can always sense
another mance should have let me take
the direwolf there would be a second
life worthy of a king he could have done
it he did not doubt the gift was strong
in snow but the youth was untaught still
fighting his nature when he should have
glory din it okay the key phrase here is
there would be a second life worthy of a
king some of you might not know this but
Jon Snow is also a war
in the books he wargs in the ghost
several times he doesn't consciously do
it like bran does but he does sense
himself inside a ghost a few times I
think this quote is actually
foreshadowing John's death and war ghing
into ghosts as he dies but it's also
foreshadowing that John is a king war
ghing into ghosts as you die would be
worthy of a king instead of just walking
into any run-of-the-mill animal and this
is exactly what John's gonna do jon is
stabbed multiple times at the end of
this book and he's about to die but
almost everyone believes he will warg
into ghosts
in fact Melisandre has seen this in her
flames she has seen John who was a man
than wolf than man again she even tried
to warn John about his enemies
sharpening their knives behind his back
but he wouldn't listen
but before John dies he has a very
interesting conversation with maester
aemon they had the same conversation in
the show but they did leave out a few
small details and there may be a reason
why they left these things out maybe
it's because it hinted at something they
didn't want revealed yet but you be the
judge maester aemon gives John one final
piece of advice and this is what he says
egg had an innocence to him a sweetness
we all loved kill the boy within you I
told him the day I took ship for the
wall it takes a man to roll an egg on
not an egg kill the boy and let the man
be born the old man felt John's face
you're half the age that egg was and
your own burden is a crueler one I fear
you will have little joy of your command
but I think you have the strength in you
to do the things that must be done kill
the boy Jon Snow winter is almost upon
us kill the boy and let the man be born
maester aemon gave this speech twice in
both times it was to an egg on the first
time he said this the same day he sailed
to the wall the second time he said this
it was the same day he sailed away from
the wall very interesting and it makes
me wonder if a mon knew who John truly
was a wonder if a Mon noticed something
as he felt John's face this may also be
foreshadowing that John's real name
we'll be Aegon in the books too this
next one could be some great wordplay
too in order to understand this possible
clue there is something you have to keep
in mind other than Circe's kids the last
two Kings were Robert Baratheon and the
Mad King when those two kings are
described they are called a drunkard in
a madman obviously Robert is the drunk
and the Mad King is the mad man now
let's look at these next few quotes to
see the connection Barristan Selmy could
not dispute that he had spent the best
part of his own life obeying the
commands of drunkards and madmen
that's referencing sell me being a
Kingsguard to Robert and the Mad King
then Tywin says the Jaime you've served
as a glorified bodyguard for two kings
one a madman and the other a drunk he is
talking about Robert and the Mad King
now let's look at a quote describing
something about Jon Snow Jon laughed
laughed like a drunk or a madman and his
men laughed with him now you could say
that doesn't mean anything
or you could say that's a very clever
way of George telling us that John is a
king himself now let's take a look at
something from a Clash of Kings this is
when Jon meets gilja Craster's keep and
Gilly is looking for help her breath
frosted the air in small nervous puffs
they say the King gives justice and
protects the weak she started to climb
off the rock awkwardly but the ice had
made it slippery and her foot went out
from under her Jon caught her before she
could fall and he helped her down safely
the woman knelt on the icy ground okay
so let's dissect this Gilly said Kings
give justice and protect the weak then
Gilly nearly falls and busts her ass but
Jon catches her and helps her safely
down Jon literally protected Gilly from
falling he protected the weak like a
king is supposed to then Gilly
immediately kneels before him as if he's
a king maybe this is a clue that Jon
really is a king or maybe it's not the
last one I want to show you is pretty
interesting I think the first part takes
place in a Davos chapter Davos is
talking to Sir Axl
warrant and this is what he tells Davos
the lady Melisandre tells us that
sometimes rule or permits his faithful
servants to glimpse the future in flames
it seemed to me as I watched the fire
this morning that I was looking at a
dozen beautiful dancers maidens garbed
in yellow silk spinning and swirling
before a great king I think it was a
true vision sir a glimpse of the glory
that awaits His grace after we take
King's Landing and the throne that is
his by rights now remember what he saw
as he looked into the flames he saw
beautiful dancers and yellow spinning
and swirling before a great king not
just a king but a great king now let's
look at John's chapter later in the same
book John went to cut more branches
snapping each one in two before tossing
it into the flames the tree had been
dead a long time but it seemed to live
again in the fire as fiery dancers woke
within each stick of wood to whirl and
spin their glowing gowns of yellow red
and orange sir axel Florent did see this
happening before a great king and that
great king is John motherfunking snakes
are dressed in yellow are spinning in
front of John which is exactly what role
or showed Sir Florin whether any of this
is actual clues or not is up for debate
but what had happened so often it's kind
of hard to dismiss I believe this just
goes to show how George is a master at
planting seeds and leaving a tiny bread
trail that is very hard to notice during
your first read-through but if you trust
the theory and then read the books again
and consciously look for the signs you
can find them just like I did I'm sure
there are plenty more that I missed and
if you know any more please let me know
down in the comments anyways what do you
think about these quotes and how they
were worded do you believe they are
clues or hints about who John really is
or do you think I'm looking too far into
this I am interested in hearing what you
have to say thank you all so much for
stopping by and watching the video I
really do appreciate that and I also
want to thank everyone on patreon for
continuing to support the channel have a
great day
I will see you in the next video bye
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]